[Music]  dear Lord but your only angel be with me  evil form they have no power into your  hands I commend myself my body and soul  congratulations on your command will  always be looking for you leaving even  if I'm a thousand miles away  Hera's going to Greyhound you will now  be out of a range of air cover for the  next five days I'm safe travels to  England  how many crossings disis make this is my  face I got some most like a youthful  kill distress Rockets sir  we hits directly from the convoy  you know daughter Belle  eight hours we've lost seven ships  what you did yesterday gotta stick today  enough not nearly enough  [Music]  target's disappeared sir  [Applause]  they come are we gonna do will rain hell  down from on high  [Music]